bureau every man in this village is a
liar an education in war is her
nominated book
up next edwin black looks at the
dispossession of the jews of baghdad in
1941 and the alliance between the mufti
of jerusalem hajj amin al-husseini and
adolf hitler
the author speaks at the park east
synagogue in new york city for about an
hour and a half
i'm happy to appear here at naos
is my sound okay the way we're going to
do this is i'm going to make my
presentation
then i'm going to take questions and
answers the first questions and answers
i take will
have been submitted in advance by people
around the world who were aware of this
event but were unable to attend whether
they are here in new york or in miami or
in london or anywhere else in addition
to that
uh after we're done with that i will
take questions from the audience on any
topic as usual i will ask you for no
statements no speeches just questions so
we can get as many questions
as we can answered that are pressing and
important to you on any topic that we
can
then after the event i'll be in the back
if anyone needs a book
so the topic we're discussing today is
the farhood the roots of the arab nazi
alliance
in the holocaust
what is the farhood
the farhood
is a nazi arab pogrom
against the jews of baghdad on june 1st
and june 2nd 1941
this was an attempt
to exterminate
completely the jews of baghdad and of
iraq it didn't quite go off the way they
had planned it and it was just a
terrible
uh program and um i will explain exactly
what happened but the farhood the word
the firehood is actually
an iconic symbol
for the arab nazi alliance in the
holocaust
because how is it
that a group of people that were
dwelling in a land
for
2600 years the jews of mesopotamia of
iraq
a thousand years before muhammad
came
to be considered to be vermin
intervention which is german for
sub-human
and were expelled from their own homes
and subject to efforts to uh
to perpetrate a genocide how did this
occur how is it that the nazis
who were
anti-semitic made in alliance
with the arabs
who were semites
what's a semite
a semite
is the children of the descendants of
noah noah had three sons one of them
washed
those descendants including abraham were
semites or semites so the arabs and the
jews are of different
stems of the abrahamic
tree
how is it that the nazis
who hated arabs who hated semites were
able to make an alliance
against uh the british and the jews what
was the purpose
well the purpose was oil what was the
reason the reason was oil
now we'll get into all
all of that i'd also like to say that
the far hood
this one per gram was just one per gram
in one city and after it
well the alliance went into the
battlefield from paris to palestine
from
uh intelligence operations to parachute
uh
platoons to artillery brigades
this was not one musty of jerusalem
but a mass movement
of tens of thousands of muslims and
these tens of thousands of muslims
were in a direct alliance of open
genocide against the jews
now i have to explain something we're
going to be talking about very sensitive
stuff
my information is completely historical
it's the 20th century not the 21st
century
so nothing in what i say as unhappy as
it is to hear
should be used as a pretext to move
against or have a a negative reaction
against any of our neighbors but i do
feel
that unless a legacy of hate can be
confronted we will never have a future
of peace
and we have to understand that the
legacy of hate
that created
the firehood
created the uh holocaust
created the middle east
that grew out of the holocaust
is in many ways with us today
once again
it's important to keep this discussion
completely historic
if anyone tries to draw me into a
contemporary discussion i'm not going to
be drawn into it because i'm here only
talking about the academic history i
should say
that there were
more than a dozen volunteers
in five countries who helped to research
this book there's a website for the book
called farhoodbook.com
farhood is
f-a-r-h-u-d
i have my own website at edwinblack.com
and there are probably more than a
thousand footnotes as we reviewed
thousands of archives we reviewed the
yiddish press the german press the
american press the arabic press
the nazi press
the nazi diplomatic papers the arab
diplomatic papers and we try to do a
thorough job to vet the process in fact
some of the people are who helped me
provide the book
to you are in the audience today
with that i'll start
reading and i'd like to get a copy of
the book can we have a copy brought up
so when did
the hatred
for the jews begin in the
muslim world
and why did it last as long as it lasted
well the history shows us remember we're
talking history here
the history shows us just a moment
the history shows us
that the beginning of the arab hatred
and the muslim hatred for the jews began
in 627
when the jews of medina were
exterminated by muhammad
medina you've heard of mecca and medina
medina was largely
a jewish city
in fact the word madinat
comes from hebrew there was in fact no
arabic at the time of the quran
it was written in a combination of
hebrew
and
syriac
the original
prayers
bowing down
were to jerusalem
and after the jews of medina refused to
convert
it turned to mecca
and the jews were exterminated one by
one by having their heads severed
by muhammad and his colleagues then came
the
islamic
conquest
of all of the arabian peninsula into the
middle east
into north africa this is the
well-documented muslim
conquest
and that is how
uh the
muslim world
became is
became established now i'm going to
remind i'm going to remind people that
this is a sensitive topic and i want to
talk history only
not
not contemporary affairs
my job is
history
you you will determine
the present tense not the uh and you
will determine the future
okay
so
the jews
of
of the arabian peninsula and the middle
east
when the muslims took it over
became dimmies
not just the jews also the christians
and this meant that they were a
protected group within the islamic world
but they were had second in and
second class citizenship or third class
citizenship they weren't allowed to have
complete religious freedom and this is
important because this issue comes right
to the question of the farhood right to
the question of the arab nazi alliance
and write to the question of our status
today right in jerusalem
now would be
completely incorrect
to say
that the
jews as demis in the muslim world were
always kept as subhumans or as a
discriminated class
many jews
in many areas
thrived greatly
in the muslim world they were protected
in the muslim world they became great
merchant
merchants in the muslim world when the
uh muslims exposed
excuse me when
when the catholic church of spain
expelled the jews in 1492
it was the muslim world it was the
sultan who took them in and who allowed
them to thrive and he took them in not
to carry stones up to build a pyramid or
sphinx he brought them in to thrive into
and to
make the empire stronger
so there were many times when jews were
either
horribly persecuted
or great or greatly emancipated within
the context of the dimmy world but
whenever they excelled
they excelled his dimmies
when they were put down they were put
down as dimmies there is no way to to
generalize if you have a specific
question i will specifically answer you
now
the jews of mesopotamia
were there for 2600 years
that's a thousand years
before islam
came
to the middle east
how is it
that they were turned
into a vile
member
of the citizenry well the answer is
there's demihood there's dimitude
the nazis
how did the nazis come to make common
cause
with
the uh arabs
the answer is oil
there were never
there were never any uh countries
in the middle east
they were all created by british
petroleum and anglo-persian and by other
um
oil in
imperialistic states in the west for the
sole purpose of getting the oil oil
prior to this there were just tribes
as a result of this
this bringing in of the west
with the uh mesopotamians as a result of
of this
it made the people of mesopotamia feel
that they were being invaded and guess
what they were being invaded
they were invaded by british petroleum
they were invaded by anglo-persian oil
com company i've written a second book
about this
which is coming out next month uh the
original way i got into the firehood was
by documenting the oil in the middle
east
the question is
where did the jews fit into this
in 1933
excuse me let me go back in 1919 the
jews were given a homeland under the
balfour declaration through the league
of nations i don't want you to think
this was strictly a british enterprise
the same type of balfour declaration was
repeated by the germans
in the war the same type of balfour
declaration was repeated by the ottomans
who owned palestine the same
document the same type of declaration
was given by the united states this was
a worldwide phenomenon
in fact no one knew where palestine was
in 1919 when the balfour declaration was
made what was palestine well palestine
was actually renamed israel by the
romans in 70 a.d when the jews were
expelled it was attached to
syria it was called syria palestina this
was to wipe away the identity of the
jews in uh
in israel
eventually
during the 20th century they didn't know
if palestine was a southern part of
syria
was a northern part of africa they still
don't know there are no bomb there were
no boundary lines at that time even
today we see that there are disputes
about who there were disputes about who
owned the bottom of the uh uh peninsula
where taba was we see that there are
disputes up in lebanon so in 1919
when the jews were give when the area
was put into two states
a jewish state and arabic state
the arabs failed
to develop their own state why
because they would not coexist with jews
in palestine as equals
now when i say jews i don't mean
european jews i don't mean polish jews
and russian jews although many polish
and russian jews were behind the
settlements even yemenite jews
any jews could not come up
and settle in palestine from about 1898
those who say
that arabs and jews have always lived in
peace in palestine
are unfortunately
mistaken
in the last 150 years
from about
1898 maybe a little bit before
there was never a single day of peace
between jews and arabs in palestine
there were there were laws against the
jews coming into palestine
into palestine there were laws against
jews owning property in palestine and
these were all under the control of the
sultan
well when the jews got a homeland
in uh 1919 in 1920 as a result of the
balfour declaration and jewish national
home in the league of nations
the arabs
rebelled and there were terrible riots
against the jews now when i say a riot
against a jew in 1920 in 1921 what am i
talking about
i am not talking about
people running up and down the street
with large placards
saying palestine for the palestinians
i'm talking about
people running into synagogues
burning torahs
heads being
cracked open
babies being killed
people being beheaded
and these are the facts
1920 1921 the british mortuarial reports
say that they've never seen so many
post-mortuary
head injuries as people were constantly
bashed and bashed
just because they were jewish
in nineteen 1928
this came to a head
in 1928
the jews decided to sit down
at the wailing wall while they were
praying for yom kippur everybody here
knows what the wailing wall is this is a
remnant of solomon's temple this is the
holiest site within the jewish people
and because they tried to sit down
it violated sharia
now you remember i told you that jews
were considered second and third class
citizens within the
muslim mindset you will recall that i
said that they had second and third
class religious rights or
those rights given the feeling was that
if jews sat down
at the wailing wall
they were demonstrating the right to sit
down and sit down without permission
the british
were obligated to enforce the
pre-existing status quo
and when little old ladies tried to sit
down in 1928
the british policemen pulled the chairs
out from under them
to make them stand
now why were the arabs
so opposed to the jews sitting when they
prayed at the wailing wall
because according to arab tradition
the wailing wall
is abharaq
and that is the place where muhammad
hitched his horse
and his winged horse on the way to
heaven
you've heard of the al-aqsa mosque
the al-aqsa mosque means the furthest
mosque
and when muhammad was going to heaven
on a winged horse
he
stopped at the furthest mosque and the
furthest mosque was in jerusalem because
there were very very few muslims there
at the time during these early years uh
of the seventh century and that made
this wall holy
to the muslim world
there were many uh
decrees under the ottoman court
as you know the ottomans owned palestine
for a half a millennium for about 500
years there were many decrees that
stated jews will not be allowed to sit
but jews did sit so what was the
reaction they said do not do that again
in 1929 the jews did do it again
in 1929
the jews decided to sit down
in the middle of the summer heat when
they uh prayed
and the arabs reacted by going on a
horrible riot
they not only rioted at the old city
uh at the wailing wall by uh pulling out
the uh
papers from the wall that jews put in to
make a supplication of god they
stabbed people they shot people but then
while the police were busy in jerusalem
they went up to hebron which has been a
jewish city for uh
since the days of abraham
they went up to uh
to hebrew to hebron and undertook a
horrible massacre of the jews now what
do i say by a massacre well i mean and
i'm going to have to talk about some
very bad things here so i'm going to do
as i did
in um uh in in my book i'm going to
apologize in advance
for the history that i must give you
in fact i'm going to read i'm going to
do some reading from my book which is
something i almost never do
i'm going to say
as i said in my introduction
this book is a nightmare
i regret anyone must read it
i regret it was necessary to write
the scholar had his head his brain
extricated
and played with a football
the baker was baked in an oven
i'm not talking auschwitz here i'm
talking hebron
a visitor was crucified against a door
babies were cut in half
people were stabbed
the police in many instances
joined the muslims now i want to make it
clear
there were many muslims
who saved their
neighbors and hid them
from further
murder and uh and mass destruction
but it did occur
a state of siege was declared the
british brought in
airplanes with machine guns they
actually shot
into the streets to suppress the riots
and this was the condition
of the arab jewish existence in
palestine
in 1929
before hitler ever came to power
and this particular
monstrous
massacre
in a long line of massacres in which
this was not an anomaly this was a high
point of many high points
this occurred because jews tried to sit
down when they prayed
now comes
january 30th 1933
hitler comes to power
and the arabs say
we want hitler
they're not just fascist leaning
they're actual nazis
they petitioned to join the nazi party
they in various cities i don't want you
to think this occurred just in palestine
in jerusalem this occurred in baghdad
this occurred in cairo this occurred in
in uh in beirut this occurred in in
syria
they ran they translated mein kampf
they redacted and changed the
translation to take away the word semite
and turn it into just anti-jew hatred
instead of anti-semitic hatred so it
would not have an impact on the arabs
they wore
armbands
there's a a a place in the book where uh
the where the um arabs are with a huge
nazi flag
the syrian national socialist
party
national socialist
just like german national socialist was
a nazi party with a swastika you can
still see this
right now
on the internet their flag has not
changed it still has a swastika
pardon me
syrian
syrian national
syrian
national socialist party
and the nazis said
we don't want you
you're semites
on top of that we're talking to weimar
republic here excuse me we're talking
about the post by by my republic we're
talking about the nazi era he said
we will never let you into the nazi
party
because you must be a pure
aryan to be in a nazi party
so i said okay if you won't adopt us
we'll make our own nazi parties and
that's exactly what they made they made
many nazi parties
and they made them all over the middle
east
they ran nazi publications and they
serialized in arabic
henry ford's protocols of the elders of
zion
which was a fundamental
turning point for adolf hitler in his
war against the jews
and this
treatise today this fake protocol this
forgery is still the best-selling book
in the arab world
in addition the nazis did want to
upset the apple cart
with the british the british had the
mandate for palestine
the british had the control
over german debt
and the nazis
wanted to keep palestine
open for jews
now you remember i wrote the book about
the transfer agreement the deal between
the zionists and nazis
that brought six some sixty thousand
jews to palestine and millions and
millions of their money well that was
actually based upon the herzlian deal in
1903 with the czar
which was actually based on the mosaic
deal with the pharaoh to let my people
go with the cows and
with the cattle and sheep and goats
to come with
the nazis wanted
palestine to remain
a jewish settlement so they could force
the jews
out of europe force the jews out of
germany
and into this one place and then when
they were all in this one tiny tract of
land
they would execute the final
uh
solution to the to the jews which would
be extermination and this was something
that the arabs were deeply involved in
and when i say arabs i mean tens of
thousands of arabs
and i'll give more information about
that as i go along
i want to remember i want to remind
everybody in the middle of my speech
that this is about history nor do i wish
to say that every arab
in
palestine was unwilling to coexist
with their jewish neighbors but i have
to tell you something i'll give you an
example the nashishibi family was one of
the strongest families in jerusalem but
those who tried to coexist with the jews
just like today
are marginalized they're intimidated
they're murdered they're ostracized and
eventually the forces of hate
the forces of hate
take over
now i talked to you in the beginning
about
the beginning of this being the
extermination of the jews in medina in
627 why did i do that
was it just to find some historic
problem
no
that is what the arabs themselves
constantly spoke about in their
newspapers in their rallies on the radio
they constantly referred to the
extermination of the jews
as setting the path for their future
course
for them this was an iconic moment
for the christians it would be the
sermon on the mount for the jews it
might be the parting of the red sea
for the muslim world it is in their own
words not for me to decide and not for
you to decide
it was the extermination of the jews in
medina
and when they spoke when they recalled
this information
when they recalled it they were called
it not only within their own private
little circles they said it to adolf
hitler personally face to face eyeball
to eyeball they said it on on german
radio they they said it openly we must
exterminate the jews now i'm going to
read something
our hatred from the jews i'm going to
read this our hatred for the jews dates
from god's condemnation of them
for their persecution and rejection of
jesus christ
and their subsequent rejection later of
his chosen prophet
verily the word of god teaches us
and we implicitly believe this for a
muslim to kill a jew
ensures him an immediate entry into
heaven
and into the august presence of god
almighty
what more can a muslim want in this hard
work world
now who said this
this was not the mufti of jerusalem
this was not an arab agitator in the old
city this was the king of saudi arabia
and who was he saying it to
foreign ministry
an official
protest
of 90 minutes which i quote completely
in the book
that year was 1937
which was in the middle of the hitler
regime
as the muslims are telling the hitler
regime
you are either going to stop allowing
jews into palestine
you are either going to give us our own
state the way we want it which is
gluten free which is
free of juice
where we're going to go work with the
germans and that's exactly what they did
the reason i read that is because i
don't want you to think that i've
exaggerated
some
independent guy some little guy some
marginalistic guy like the mufti of
jerusalem but the month of jerusalem was
not
who is the central figure was not the uh
a marginal guy he was the leader
of the uh
uh arab uh the supreme muslim council
he was the grand mufti of jerusalem who
made him the grandmother of jerusalem
the british made him the grand mostly of
jerusalem he had an international
islamic following for his work
from india
to jerusalem
to yugoslavia
to london
to beirut
everywhere there was communication and
support for the arab war against the
jews
eventually
after the arabs continually beckoned the
nazis
for some form of alliance
it all came to a head when the peel
commission in the late 30s
recommended
that there be two actual states
they said we've tried for many years to
bring these two peoples together now
it's time to cut the country in half
and they said we will never coexist with
the jews in palestine
they actually said better britain should
run it as a colony for a hundred years
then we should live one day
with jews as co-equals
allowing them to sit while they pray at
the wall now i have to tell you that 99
of what you read in this book is all
quotation in context from the original
arabic from the original german from the
original english
from the original british documentation
etc etc as we tried to document
carefully
the roots of the arab nazi alliance
eventually the british began to see
that their efforts to push the jews
out
of germany
and out of europe
into palestine
was creating an actual jewish state not
just a settlement not just a big prison
cell with beaches not just a reservation
but an actual state and they thought
that is a threat to the third reich
because they believed in henry ford's
theory of an international jewish
conspiracy
at that point something else occurred
they realized as they were edging closer
closer to war in 1937 1938 they were on
beginning to understand that the british
who they hoped would join them in an
anglo-saxon uh
conquest of the
lower forms of human life
was not going to happen and war was
coming and one war would come they would
need one thing
and that one thing did not grow in
london that one thing grew in the middle
east
and that was oil
and the arabs went to the germans and
when i say they went to the germans they
went to adolf hitler personally and he
said we will give you oil if you will
kill all the jews
if you will recognize our state that in
mince words
i know and you all know
that the nazis like to talk about
extermination and code zander bahandlang
which meant gas chamber you translate it
it means
it means special treatment
the arabs made no such pretense they
said kill the jews wherever you find
them
kill a jew before he kills you it didn't
this wasn't whispered this was on the
radio night after night
broadcast in uh in internationally how
does this make its way up to the far
hood
well the firehood was in 1941 by this
time the um
the
world world war ii was in was
was in full swing
and at this point the
nazis had decided to launch operation
barbosa
to invade russia
they couldn't get it they couldn't get
there without oil
the oil in romania was that they had
used was insufficient
arab said we will give you the oil we
will give you the oil of
iraq we will give you the oil of iran we
will give you all the oil we have
if you will declare for arab state and
hitler said
i will declare for an arab state and
finish the jews when i crossed the
caucasus mountains
so it was everything
the nazi the arabs could do to make that
come to pass
at a point in time
in in the spring of 1941
the uh jews of baghdad
were on edge they had lived there for 2
600 years
but they knew that there were many arab
nazis now when i say an arab nazi
i'm not talking about a guy running
around with a swastika armband i'm
talking about hitler youth in arab lands
what do i mean by hitler youth i mean
actual
hundreds and thousands of young iraqi
jews who went to nuremberg who went to
germany to march in torchlight parades
who taught nazi
iraqi arabs excuse me
iraqi arabs who went to germany who
brought their concepts back who
organized along a german basis and who
considered themselves actual nazis
in fact i need to tell you
that the second most popular name for a
young child
in the arab world was
hitler
in fact
you could today see some people on the
internet
arabs whose name is hitler
i'll give you an example
i you can look at
google a man by the name of hitler
tantawi t-a-n-t-a-w-i
he's just an ordinary civil servant in
egypt in charge of efficiency his name
is hitler they had a little theory going
on that adolf hitler was not born in
austria adolf hitler's actual real name
was muhammad hadar he was a little
egyptian boy he had visited all the
mosques of egypt
and
he was the uh
the new savior of the arab people in
fact the posters in the marketplace said
in heaven your master is is allah
in uh on earth your master is adolf hit
is adolf hitler so in 1941 in june
june of uh just before june 1st
there was a decision to totally
exterminate the jews
they were told to
go into their homes
shut the homes stay off the phone turn
off the radio and pack their bags for
three days you all know this scenario
due to a last minute
i'll i'll use the word rescue
by one of the arab leaders who was in
good relation with the jewish people
there
he
expelled the chief arab nazi who was
doing this
and at that point
because the
extermination effect had failed there
was a mass riot
of
iraqi military men
iraqi police
and arab nazis running all over the
streets from june 1st to june 2nd
of 1941
killing
hundreds
of iraqi jews
what am i talking about i'm talking
about women being raped in front of
their parents i'm talking about parents
being raped in front of being murdered
in front of their kids i'm talking about
babies being sliced in half and thrown
into the river i'm talking about homes
being invaded and people running up to
the rooftops and jumping from rooftop to
rooftop to be escaped
for escape
and this was done with the full
knowledge
of the nazi government
they had actually given money they had
sent aircraft into to support an
operation uh just a few days before
and the
chief arab
agitator from the uh berlin government
groba
had his office there and they were
working with the mufti of jerusalem
and they were making this pogrom in
order to kill all the jews of baghdad
but it didn't work and it because it
didn't work it's been labeled a pogrom
it's been labeled
firehood what does farhood mean it means
violent dispossession
in arabic and that is a word we barely
have
in english and so they use they use one
word now there's not a sephardic jew in
the united states or in the world
listening to me who does not know what
farhood is there are many people in this
room who have worked with me to bring
this information out
it's been suppressed because they wanted
to pretend
that the war against the jews
had a bright line
a little bit north of the middle east
that is not the case the war against the
jews was not just a war against my
parents and your neighbors and you in
poland but all jews
the british
did not intervene
in this
monstrous massacre
where were the british
they were just outside of town outside
of baghdad why were they there they had
one job secure the oil
and they did secure the oil for british
petroleum
and they said if we don't secure that
oil if the nazis get that oil
they will be unstoppable
well
the nazis did not get that oil
eventually the program was stopped
because someone had the courage in the
iraqi government
which was changing form from minute to
minute to call out guards and suppress
the agitation
thereafter
the arabs changed their tactics
and said we will no longer
work with just urban riots
and and mass mayhem in the cities
will help hitler do what he wants to do
cross the caucasus mountains
come around and exterminate the jews of
palestine how well first of all we'll
make common cause with the iranians what
is what is the word iran mean the word
iran means aryan
they are the true aryans the name was
changed from persia in 1935
to invoke the ancient well-entrenched
name of iran aryan
as a salute to a massive nazi-dominated
iranian
infrastructure
so after the uh british took over the
oil wells
secured them that they'd had from
decades
in um in iraq
for years not decades they then moved
into iran
expelled the shah
brought in the man that you know is the
shah of iran
and
kicked out 2 000
nazi
agitators and military men and
advanced units that were creating
railroad systems trains all sorts of
infrastructure
events to cut iran off
from the west to cut the oil off from
the west and to give it exclusively to
nazi germany
after that the arabs said okay we're
going to switch to the battlefield
they recruited
not one muslim fighter not
one hundred
not one thousand but tens of thousands
three
s waffen ss divisions
the first was hanshar
the second was
sanderbeg
and the third was comma
and the ones and they worked mainly in
yugoslavia anyone hear from yugoslavia
no but we've seen them in europe okay
they wore feathers
now
let me tell you
what happened in yugoslavia i want you
to again accept my apology in advance
what happened in yugoslavia
was a
a manifold greater
genocide than what happened in
auschwitz they formed the muslims formed
with the catholic with the catholic
church
a bi-national
group
a bi-national genocidal group called the
eustachian
you don't hear about this much
but yustachi were the single
deadliest
most bloodthirsty
killers
in the entire world war ii era what am i
talking about
well it's awful
i'm talking about
a prison camp justinovic
where
there was a contest between the guards
on how many
throats could they slit in one night one
guy slit 1350
throats and he won the next guy did 1100
he came in second another guy did 650 he
came in third we've documented all of
this stuff
who organized this
the mufti of jerusalem
and the nazis
i'm talking about actual trench warfare
i spoke to him to a man
here who said he was in the partisans
and they fought against the partisans in
yugoslavia
thousands of them artillery brigades
parrot paratroopers infantry
this was not just a bunch of people
rabble rousing in the street this was
not just a bunch of people on the radio
this were people this was a group
helping hitler wage his war against
humanity
it's very difficult when you talk about
yugoslavia because you have serbs greek
orthodox church catholics
some jews
you have muslims bosniak muslims
and the alliances changed by the minute
by the hour
it was a murderous mix
and we've seen it today
in that same part of the world
but
the truth is
that the worst crimes of the holocaust
were committed by this muslim catholic
alliance
as a
clients of the nazis in hugo in
yugoslavia
eventually
hitler lost the war
but
the holocaust stopped
in may of 1945 but then it continued
in the middle east
as
all of the uh infrastructure that had
been put into place by the arabs
to make common cause with the nazis to
destroy the jews
now came into their own middle east
countries they invaded israel and they
invaded not to restore palestinian
rights
not to restore their land but quote to
exterminate the jews
they even used the reference to genghis
khan you know they had a phrase
and this phrase was invented in the
1920s
not in the 1930s not in 1940s
philistine
bladna philistine bladna
palestine is our land they would run
down up and down the streets and they
would scream
palestine
vladna palestine is their land but it
was actually a rhyme
here's the second half of the rhyme
palestine
yahood
palestine is our land the jew is our dog
this was not in 1945 this was in 1920.
this was in 19 this was not 1939 this
was in 1920. this wasn't once this was
a regular chant
and i'm trying to give you the mindset
the roots of the arab nazi alliance
in the holocaust
and so all these guys whose names were
hitler and all these guys whose names
were adolf
found common cause after world war ii in
fact some 2 000 nazis prison guards
gestapo ss
migrated into the middle east into egypt
to egypt we have their names in the
in in the book for the sole purpose of
waging war against israel with
propaganda with boycott disinvestments
in and
and sanction
with um military maneuvers
wars
the independence war the war of
independence in 1948 and all the other
wars that came to pass
arab
nazi masterminds when i say nazi i mean
german masterminds
were working behind the scenes and
indeed
in the front on their arab names
bringing this to reality now what does
this mean for us today
well we have to look today
when we see a guy called muhammad abbas
mahmud abbas
who says i will never recognize israel
as a jewish state
they can call themselves anything we
want this hearkens back
to the concept
of we will never allow we will never
allow ourselves to coexist with jews in
palestine
now you may say why didn't you mention
this and why didn't you mention that
i didn't mention about 99 of everything
that's in the book
and
the book only meant didn't mention 99 of
everything we could have done because
every chapter we did in the book has
could have been a book unto itself for
perhaps a small bookshelf of books
but i did endeavor
to give clarity
to how it is from their perspective the
arabs were
able to form an alliance during the
holocaust with the nazis
how it
nurtured itself over 1400 years how it
played out during the war
and how it continued after the war in
the 20th century
and as you know the 21st century is
owned by the 20th century
why did it happen
no oil
no iraq
no british petroleum
no need for middle east wars
it was oil
no one ever went to mesopotamia to iraq
because they enjoyed the sand
it was only what was underneath the sand
that brought them and that is what
the uh arabs and the muslims of that
world world
reviled and not just the muslims in
palestine not just in
in iraq
in iran
but also yugoslavia
india
london etc what is the message here
the message is
that we want to use this information
as a truth and reconciliation
so we can understand how we got here
do not misuse my information
to recreate
a new legacy of hate
but use it to confront a legacy of hate
so we can move forward
with all people in the middle east
to create a future of peace
the germans and the jews
have reconciled
never forget but they're co they're co
they're coexisting is allies
and that began
believe me in june of 1945 if not before
it is possible it is difficult
it is difficult when it's not 13 years
as it was for the third rack but 1400
years but with this information i hope
to arm you with what you need to
understand our presence understand our
past thank you
and now i'll take questions but first
i'm going to take some remote questions
which have been given to us in advance
by various people
around the country and
overseas uh the first question
and then i'll take questions from the
audience
um how much time do i have
as much as i want okay
okay
um
here's a question from a guy called
mitch debach at the university of miami
who studies middle east history
he talks about the fact that
the book documents the exp
which i did not mention that the jews
were expelled from arab lands about a
million jews just a little less than a
million jews after world war ii were
expelled
from german uh
from arab lands into israel all their
money was taken they emulated the
eichmann
program
and it says
do i support current efforts of israel's
foreign ministry to include in feud in
future peace talks
when addressing the issue of refugees
the case of 800 to 900 000 jews of arab
lands
staying out of contemporary affairs
i will tell you that at the time this
this occurred a half a century ago
the israeli foreign ministry
said
we will have to keep this in reckoning
the dispossession of the jews from
morocco from libya from
from iraq from all from all these
different con
countries in our um uh balancing
of peace justice and reinfriend
re-enfranchisement uh in the middle east
in israel
there is no question there are people in
this room today who work every day
to argue for the return
of property i know that uh leo here and
many others are looking for the returns
of their property in poland in
czechoslovakia in germany
in
parts of russia there are many jews
in the arab world who were left
penniless what do i mean by penniless
they took them out they pulled the rings
out of their ears
they took the bracelets from their uh
arms
and they did everything possible to
leave them penniless why
because the arabs thought
we don't have the manpower
to kill all the jews
and we don't wish to now
although they did have
concentration camps in north africa we
don't have the manpower to do that so
what we will do is we'll create a
demographic bomb we'll flood a million
jews into israel they won't know what to
do with them they'll be on the beach
and israel will collapse
that did not occur
arabs were kept in
in refugee camps for decades the jews
were
were absorbed into israeli society
immediately and as you all know who's
running the uh israeli government today
uh one way or the other it's um in many
instances jews of uh um uh who came from
arab countries so they that they were
not marginalized they were not left to
die on the sand so this is a historic
truth that you must acknowledge what is
uh what happened to a million jews who
were in the middle class
and the upper class who were in the
established mercantile class in the
government were expelled penniless a
second question here
comes from miami
was submitted by email
how does
uh let's see it it talks about um
in light of what you have discovered
about the yustashi
the muslim catholic alliance
that murdered
tens tens and tens of of jews and sir
and serbians and also muslims many
muslims died
at their hands
how does this relate to our
understanding of recent international
events involving kosovo and
all of this well
i can't tell you how complicated
yugoslavia is i can't tell you how many
uh
partial countries
temporary countries territories dukedoms
kosovo bosnia albania
they all came and went they all came and
went they had different alliances to
kill each other
the
catholics at one point decided that all
the muslims were going to be honorary
catholics or honorary croatians and they
formed the yustashi
yes
we should always understand
always understand
that whatever we have today
did not appear suddenly it is a legacy
here's a question
and this comes from lester frank lester
m frank from los angeles
how does any of this relate to the bds
movement the so-called boycott dis
investment and sanction movement against
israel we hear about this all the time
what are the historical roots of this
movement
well you hear about this boycott israel
thing when did this start this started
in uh january 30th of 1933 actually
april of 1933 when the mufti of
jerusalem went to the arab consulate in
jerusalem and said we're ready to join
the nazi boycott against the jews
and from that it percolated
as a continuous effort to deny
identification to legitimacy to
and commerce with the uh
jews in palestine it got so bad that uh
in the latter 30s that if a jew a dead
if an arab taxi took a jew across town
that arab taxi driver could be killed so
the bds movement is absolute the one we
see today
is as much a legacy of the arab nazi
alliance of hate as anything else that i
have discussed
and now do you have one
here's a question from london from in an
iraqi jew
my question is was the farhood
premeditated or spontaneous this is from
lynn julius of london
lynn
julius
was it pre-meditated the answer is yes
it was absolutely premeditated it did
it didn't work out the way they wanted
to they didn't exterminate all the jews
in concentration camps or gas chambers
so they did the next best thing that
killed every jew they could get their
hand on and they killed him as viciously
as humanly possible
and now i will take questions from here
uh there's a mic here and let's go with
this woman first
can everybody here hear me okay thank
you mr black for this extraordinary
panorama of the
arab
uh muslim
uh nazi alliance and for drawing for us
the continuity of this issue thank you
way back what is your question my
question is simply very simple i've
always heard that the grand mufti was
instrumental in all these events and i
would love it if you could give us a few
more details about the persona of this
man
the grand mufti of jerusalem
was um uh
was made a mufti by the british and then
to make him a bigger mufti they made him
a grand mufti and he was put into power
for the sole purpose of keeping the uh
um arabs of palestine into some kind of
tranquility
and the reason for that was they were
trying to build at that at that time and
ultimately did build a pipeline from
iraq to haifa to bring all the british
petroleum uh oil to the um
to the allies and to the western world
now british petroleum's name at that
time was not called uh british petroleum
was called ang it was called
anglo-persian and many other names
so the mufti of jerusalem
had a shadow government
he he was given virtual auto or autonomy
he was on the british pay roll
he had uh his own uh
his own infrastructure and he had
control over the western wall he had
control over al-aqsa mosque and he was a
huge agitator
and it was typical for him to uh speak
in front of the microphone and say i
want everybody not to to engage in any
kind of violence
and then in the side he would say kill
the jews kill them where they are so
there was speaking with two different
voices one for the western world and one
for the arab world this is a tradition
that goes back to the mufti and we've
given all these this information in in
the diplomatic cables in the arabic
cables we tried our hardest to quote the
arabic um communications at the time
so the musty of jerusalem was devious he
um uh
was part and parcel at the highest level
with uh the hitler regime he met with it
he met with hitler in his in his office
he was on the hitler payroll he was um
given he he was elevated by hitler and
when i say he was with hitler i don't
mean that he was just uh meeting in a
dark shadow they had newsreels in fact
the mufti of jerusalem went to
concentration camps he went to
zachsenhausen he went to the place where
all the concentration camps iranianburg
were organized he went uh we believe to
a subset of auschwitz and
whenever they tried to rescue jews the
mufti of jerusalem would send um uh uh
irrepressible letters to the hungarian
officials to the polish officials saying
don't not to the polish to the hungarian
to the bulgarian saying don't send the
jews to palestine send them to poland
okay now if you think
that uh nobody knew what auschwitz was
in uh 1941 excuse me 1942-1943
let me correct you
because a little girl in
an attic in holland
confirmed in her diary the jews are
being gassed in poland
the bbc was broadcasting this and i have
reproduced the exact language of a book
published by the afl-cio
worldwide in numerous languages
including the united states explaining
that auschwitz is a death camp where
they put gas in the cellar this was very
well
known and so when he said send them to
poland he knew what he was doing thank
you very much i hope i've answered your
question now the sec
now the second question comes from here
go ahead the question is
what now
you know you you you he you hinted
before when you ended you
where do we who do we turn to because in
in in europe when we saw the ustashes
coming to uh they uh the
bosnian muslims were coming with wearing
fezzes in the in warsaw i saw them
personally in warsaw with the totem cop
on their feathers there was a whole
regiment of of uh
and
coming
moving forward we had our government the
american government sent
bombs on the serbians the serbians
had michalovich
but
let me try to answer the question yes
um
yes
the as i've explained
the
muslim forces
of the uh third reich who were not just
independent militias they were uh
nss units were dispatched all over
europe in various
formations for various tasks although
they were mainly
centralized in uh
in um uh yugoslavia they were trained in
france
um your question is
and you know about this from personal
experience because you saw you saw them
what do we do now
that question will not be answered by me
that question will be answered by
everyone who hears you
i have given you the history of how we
got to this
i will not talk about 21st century
policy but
any 21st century policy which is
attempting justice must look back on the
true facts of his of of of of history
there were many uh there was enough
bloodletting in yugoslavia to write
volumes and volumes and unfortunately
what our government does now in the
middle east in yugoslavia et cetera is
up to a sense of justice
in history and you
and you will decide what that is and not
me thank you very much
excuse me you said for lack of knowledge
i hope i addressed that in this book and
in this conversation
uh now i'm going to take uh uh uh one
question from this side please hear you
say that the mufti was on the british
payroll yes the mufti was getting
something like 60 000 uh pounds a year
uh on the british payroll and when he
left the british pay really went to the
nazi page
prior to world war ii of course now i'm
going to take a question from this
gentleman here his name is [ __ ]
alfassa
and uh [ __ ] uh is with uh
jews for justice for jews from arab
countries he's intimately familiar with
this knowledge what's your question
[ __ ] i had a personal question um the
u.s holocaust museum
as we both know
was not very keen to discuss this topic
five years ago
can you tell me that if in the last few
years
they're still not talking about this
topic or have they addressed it okay
the question is whether or not the u.s
holocaust museum has consciously
obstructed information about this topic
well the answer is of course yes and
many people in this organization of
survivors know how difficult uh it has
been to
get the management of the museum to be
truthful and cooperative on many issues
in the um
i believe it was five years ago that
there was an attempt to get recognition
of the far hood this man was involved
many other scholars were involved and
the holocaust museum uh put a stop to it
by sending out emails to to all the
other holocaust museums because their
narrative was
that the um that the uh holocaust
experience
hitler's war against jews was a european
experience i'm sure you all know the
hillberg book destruction of the
european
jewry but that does not mean that just
miles south of there the jews were not
destroyed in belgrade which was of
course the uh first uh uh
uh
jewish free city juden reign that they
were not horrible concentration camps in
the uh north of africa i always have to
say that many jews who survived the
holocaust in north africa did so because
they're arab muslims in north africa
helped them
and saved
and saved them but that does not mean
that there were not multitudes
there were not multitudes of arabs in
common cause the holocaust museum
obstructed uh
that move by svardic jews
in the last several years they have
reformed they've made progress there is
now a page on their website about the
far hood they have now putting in some
information about the mufti i believe
you launched a complete what was your
involvement in uh pressuring the museum
to come clean
at the time i was executive director of
the international sephardic leadership
council and i had asked
um peter black who was uh was i don't
know if he still is
the chief historian of the holocaust
museum no relation by the way
i went to the holocaust museum
as a tourist and asked him some
questions and he denied any uh
responsibility of the mufti and
the nazis in north africa
which is just not true and what happened
there after there was a protest movement
against the holocaust i called for i uh
we sent the press release on nationally
calling for uh his firing because the
u.s holocaust memorial museum refused to
speak with us about the topic and uh
basically shut the door in anything
related to the farhood you know the
holocaust museum's mission statement is
about the
the uh showa in europe they don't
mention anything of the shoah in north
africa or the middle okay and by the way
did anyone in congress take up your
cause
we did congressman elliot engel uh came
with me to the national synagogue and uh
basically said on stage
along with rabbi yavi weiss that um you
know he'd work to cut the funding to the
holocaust museum unless they spoke about
this topic okay so now the holocaust
museum has made strides i applaud those
stripes but just so you understand
all my research at the holocaust museum
was blocked
on the eustachian they would they um
andy hollinger denied me the right to
the only institution in the world that
denied me the right to speak to their
mustachy experts
their yugoslavian expert
and
i'm very sad about it i know that uh
they've refused the people in this room
the survivors in this room the right to
their own records from bob arlson um
leo rector here has been fighting this
cause
our job here is to once again hope that
we can move forward progressively with
the holocaust museum to broaden their
point of view and
allow
stop
stop their confrontation with survivors
give them their records
and
open up their files and their experts to
anyone not just me but anyone who wishes
to speak to an expert
because these are very complicated files
should should be able to uh do do so
i'll take a question
it's really not a question it's a
statement is that we don't want any
statements let's ask a question i just
want to ask you isn't that an irony that
germany today has such an unbelievable
problem with the arabs excuse me uh
i'm sorry it's not something i'm going
to address it does not have a place in
this con conversation i'm only talking
about the holocaust era i have a
question from you
when you refer to the nazi machinery was
still operating after the official
disintegration of the holocaust
to further the arab movement against the
jews
are you referencing this is my
understanding that they were the
werewolves
well you can call them the werewolves
you can call them the uh uh the secret
foxes you can call them the vampires you
can call them whatever you want but they
were in official positions not
unofficial positions they were running
the propaganda movements they were
running the military coordination their
name their first names were hitler or
adolf or things of that nature and uh
this generation of nazis of doctrinary
nazis uh transferred into the arab world
to create the middle east that we know
today so and that is in the book a
question from this side you draw very
clear historical lines between of the
jew hatred in the middle eastern world
but you also allude to some positive
behaviors and protection of jews so i'm
wondering if you can elaborate on that
so that we can use this maybe also as a
foundation for future hope sure i'm
happy to uh anyone who wants to say that
it's all arabs or it's all muslims is
totally wrong they're
misinterpreting what i'm saying i'm
talking i mean remember
no one has hesitated to document what
the germans did in world war ii
was it every german no
uh was it every poll no
what
was was it every let me tell you
something most peop most french jews
today are alive because a frenchman
in france helped save them
that is true
now what can we use today well people
say to me is there no hope
how do you defeat 1400 years of hatred
listen
there's a peace treaty with jordan
there's a peace treaty with
with
egypt
this is called coexistence
and coexistence can lead to peace so
when you come out of here
don't find a reason
to amplify what happened in the 20th
century find a reason to move forward in
handshake and brotherhood with arabs
with muslims to look back on the history
as they have in south africa as they
have in yugoslavia as they have in
rwanda and move forward and say now what
can we do from here looking at our
honest history so use the precedent but
you also alluded to
actual
arabs who protect the jews back
throughout history uh arab
arabs
arab regimes
depending upon the decade pretending
upon the century depending upon the
territory have alternately massacred the
jews
or elevated them to uh elite no no
ability and i try to give the nuances of
that in the book there's a huge legacy
of uh neighborliness between jews and
arabs but i also had to give the con the
context absolutely i mean you know what
we can say about black people in this
country that black people in this
country they rose they became great
sports stars they became great jazz guys
but they came great jazz guys and great
sports stars within the constant text
of the civil rights movement within the
context of being
of being suppressed and uh being
subjected to the cruelest of uh uh jim
crow laws and things of that nature so
yes were there blacks with plenty of
money sure did they have to fight three
times as hard to get there yes they did
and so yes there were good relations
i'm happy
to to emphasize the good relationships
even in the firehood
and the book makes this clear
many times
a jewish family was saved by an arab in
fact the reason the extermination itself
did not go true is true thousands of
arabs in mesopotamia murdered
hundreds of jews
but there were also a few key arabs who
saved it from becoming total
extermination and they are named and
they must be recognized
and not marginalized a question on this
side how much time do i have left
15. okay i wanted to know if you are
invited to speak on this issue to
university campuses
okay
okay the answer is
okay
the answer is i do about 300 events a
year
and i'm doing many events on this topic
at universities
i'll be
i have a website called edwinblack.com
my
schedule is open i'm not hiding from any
from anyone
uh you can go to my multi-book tour of
2009 2011 and you will see i have 15
events in south florida i've got
five or ten events in uh san francisco
bay in january in feb and february
so i speak as often as possible but i
have to tell you something
there are many people who don't want
this message
and not all these and some people within
the jewish community itself do not want
this message discussed
my challenge
is to bring this history out none
without politics without uh
uh um
uh without polemics
and to use it as a basis for fact
and moving forward
in brotherhood with our neighbors not as
a not as a way to fractionalize us yes i
have a question for you in in judah
englemaier in my work with you helping
you research the book i i came to some
sort of conclusions on my own
um
a lot of what went on in the 20th
century since israel has been formed a
lot of the the negotiations for peace
process and and negotiating and also
problems that jews have around the world
everyone says a lot of people often say
i'm not anti-jewish i'm anti-israel i'm
not anti-i'm i'm it's if israel wasn't
there israel wasn't oppressing israel
wasn't doing that your book clearly
outlines that the nazis who claim
they're anti-semitic are actually
anti-jewish because they changed that
tone from anti-semitic to being just
anti-jewish in the end they just wanted
to get rid of the jews what do you say
to people who who differ try to
differentiate between being israel
anti-israel and anti-jewish in a scheme
of things when you when you look at the
research that you've done in this book
and some other books it becomes only
about one thing and one thing only in my
opinion
well
you are correct and you were in our
research effort and when i say you were
in the research effort you were there
hour to hour and minute to minutes for
many many months as we constantly
struggled to document this as fairly and
in context as we could from all sides
being careful not to leave anything out
the answer is
it is anti-jewish not anti-zionist
the jews are in
their homeland
so the vocabulary used is anti-zionist
but
decades before
there was
a state of israel in 1948 in 1920 in
1921 decades before that they were still
singing
palestine is our land the jew is our dog
so this does not involve a sudden uh
appearance of an inf of uh
of a reactive uh hatred you know i saw a
guy come on the jon stewart show and he
was in charge of this boycott against
israel he said well jews and arabs have
always lived in peace in palestine not a
day
not a day
not an hour if you find one if anyone
finds one if anyone finds a day let me
know
did the jews and arabs live in peace in
palestine either they were demis
or they were before 1898 or they were
reviled
after 1898 for their zionist cause and
remember
the idea that jews could not sit down at
the wall
was kept alive
elevated the mufti and became a cause
for the whole muslim world for years and
years and even today
even today there are efforts to deny the
jews the right to claim the wailing wall
is their religious place
based on the information i've given you
one more question do we have time for
one more a question from this woman here
we're going from left to right
okay
it's never emphasized enough that the
arabs actually didn't discover the oil
they had
they didn't discover the oil the oil
fields actually they were searching for
water
all right uh let me uh who discovered
the oil uh since i've written many books
on oil and since i've got another book
coming out uh next month called british
petroleum and the red line agreement
their history i can tell you this oil is
older than civilization
the first oil was being used by cavemen
in south africa 60 000 years ago in
blumbus
uh there was oil in the 1800s
uh in the middle east
and but the exploration teams the
industrial oil the oil with with the
gushers that you know about this was
discovered by the british uh the first
one in iraq being in um
at uh baba gagar and we have pictures of
that in in in my next book i also wrote
a book called banking on baghdad in
which i explained the whole history of
that so
whether or not the arabs discovered the
oil
only reinforces their view that their
land
was given to someone else
to bring a
non-islamic presence a non-arabic
presence into their country and this has
only intensified the jihad the original
jihad against the west was born in 1920
and that's in the book too was not born
in in uh september 11th it was born in
1920 and it was a reaction to jews in
palestine in his reaction to oil
companies in iraq
one more question i'll take one more
question from this guy
adjustment give just a minute we're
waiting for the furthermore don't add a
statement just ask
add a question please
would you have said do you hear me you
have said before about hajime al-hussein
he had an office near hitler in in
berlin that's right and there was a
problem
he they made him a general about to make
him a general in the assess they
couldn't make him a general because he
was a semite so the problem was solved
he was not an arab he was a turk
and therefore it was impossible to make
a in general in the other what is your
question
there's no question is that true i'm
making a statement okay
all right fine uh do we have time for
one more question all right here's the
gentleman heroes come give us a question
20th century please
uh you mentioned the renaissance what is
your name andrew yeah
what's up um you mentioned how iran was
changed from persia to iran yeah and how
it had roots with
indigenous ties to nazi party and trying
to appeal to hitler's nazi party but how
many people in iran or worldwide
acknowledge the roots of this
name change and what other factors
contributed to the creating of the name
iran
the name iran
when i first brought this out
some years ago in some articles i was
subjected to a massive intimidation
campaign
uh which means nothing i stood up to ibm
so i can stand up to everybody
um and um
the name iran is an ancient name
that goes back thousands of years
and the swastika
is actually
uh
in iranian or persian symbol
in india i'm talking about it
it is backwards but it came down through
the indus okay now somewhere in the
night in the 19th century
there was a um i'd like to make it uh
clear that in
in the book we indicate that the um
that the roots of the swastika but you
see it in ancient pottery of of of the
iranians
around the
19th century there was a mix-up of the
words
and the scandinavians thought that they
were the actual aryans and this allowed
this fake
aryan race cult
to exist which was medicalized by the
rockefeller foundation and the carnegie
institution and henry ford into the
concept of eugenics which i also wrote a
book called war against the weak and
nazi nexus
does the world recognize this
no do you recognize it yes
another question
yes ma'am
just a second do you remember by any
chance what was the name of that person
in
croatia who was
in famous for having in his office a
basket of human eyes
all right
the woman says do i remember the name of
the guy
in croatia
who had a basket of eyeballs
in his office
showing it uh that is referred to
on pages 327 and 335
and uh i don't want to take the time to
read it here but we have his name and we
had access to the yustashi film archives
um
and he he showed them off there was 40
pounds of eyes of eyeballs
and now i am out of time i'll take just
one more question does anybody have
another question yes ma'am ask your
question
excuse me you had said that uh their
predominant name was adolf and hitler
both in the past and what happened to
those names do they disappear or are
there adolf juniors hitler juniors
okay
what happened to all the arabs and all
the muslims who decided to name their
kids
adolf
well most of them thought that this is
not the best name to have
uh in a post-war period
and they cast off those names
anyone can change their name
like that
and most of them did but some of them
didn't and the ones that didn't you can
find um decades later in fact
i will read to you if i have a moment
uh a very unfortunate letter
and this is an imaginary letter written
in
to adolf hitler after he died
and this letter
says as follows
it says
dear adolf hitler
uh
i i wish that you had triumphed i have
the exact text here i wish that you had
triumphed i you are the greatest thing
that ever happened and one day you will
come back and i wish the arab world
would have a hitler too and that was
written to a egyptian newspaper
paper and the man who wrote that letter
was anwar sadat
in fact i have pictures of anwar sadat
coming to jerusalem and his tie is
covered with swastikas
in jerusalem
anyway thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen
thank you
edwin black is the author of several
books including ibm and the holocaust
and internal combustion how corporations
and governments addicted the world to
oil and derailed the alternatives to
find out more visit his website
edwinblack.com
visit booktv.org to watch any of the
programs you see here online